[Music]
starting off this hour is gonna be Robin
in Tennessee hey Robin welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thanks for taking my
call
sure so out of the blue today my
mother-in-law all of a sudden asked for
my kids Social Security card she said
she wants to open a savings account in
their name and I am wondering if this is
a wise decision to give her those or if
there's a better option that we could
steer tour so that she can still you
know savory kids like she wants to is
there another reason that your
mother-in-law is untrustworthy to have
your children social um not that I know
of it just it really caught me off guard
and she wanted them like right now this
minute kind of thing and it just really
threw him off hurt and make me uneasy
and I wanted to find out is that even
something that we should be doing okay
um and if there's if the relationship
with your mother-in-law is okay and
she's an okay person there's no harm no
foul at all but it sounds like something
else is going on here well she and I
don't have a good relationship but the
kids oh and what about your husband
oh I get sort of cut in the middle okay
all right so she's bossy thank you
and this was like one more time she just
was trying to do a command performance
she likes telling everybody what to do
and seeing how high they jump yeah and
you don't like jumping I don't blame you
I don't mind you so um well what I would
do is just say hey um you know I'm gonna
talk with your son my husband and we'll
discuss you know what we think is the
best route with our children appreciate
your generosity and you know we'll get
back to you in a couple days and let her
sit that's has nothing to do with
financial that has to do with managing
mother-in-law's it is it's perfectly
normal as a grandpa if I wanted as Papa
Dave if I wanted to open an account in
the kids name and I wanted to be the
custodian and I wanted to put name money
in the kids name as long as the parents
were all okay with that
with a relationship part of it there's
no legal
there's no danger there's no nothing I
would need the Social Security number of
my grandchild to do that now in our case
what we have done instead is Sharon and
I we've chosen to let our children the
grandchildren's parents being you manage
the money because we trust their ability
to manage the money and we're not trying
to control freaks so we just give them
money and say hey why don't you open up
an ESA in the kid's name or a 529 the
kids neighbor put this in the 529 you
already got open or something like that
right I mean we might make a suggestion
we just give him a check but we don't we
don't try to minute but we trust their
ability to handle the money and our
relationships are all strong do you see
the difference oh yeah so but all it is
is a custodial account which you name an
adult as the custodian who's in charge
of the money until the child is 21 and
then the you have to have a kids social
security number to open that account the
child is the beneficiary so there's no
downside it's not like but if she's like
a scum burger and she's doing cocaine or
something you don't want her having
anybody social security number because
she's gonna do identity theft and use it
to open credit cards and the kids name
so she can buy coke or something if
that's the kind of stuffs going on you
would never give it to him right but but
that's a different issue that's not a
really a financial issue so I it sounds
to me like more like you were tired of
being told what to do and you know
suddenly she decide she's gonna do
something throw our weight around and
you just don't like that I don't blame
you let's this is good time to put a
little put a bridle on mama
so and the way we're gonna do that's
just say tap the brakes till I talk to
my husband and you know we'll get back
to you thank you for the thought though
mom that's a wonderful generous thing to
want to do something for the kids we
appreciate that